en 1923 et le premier président
américain à mettre le pied au Canada
c'est une escale avant couvert il vient
d'Alaska très malade il précipite son
retour vers San Francisco où il va
mourir deux jours plus tard il laisse
avant couvert le souvenir d'un
chaleureux discours qu'on marquera d'un
monument à Stanley Park
line de l'anneau Roosevelt viendra huit
fois au Canada d'abord sa famille a une
maison sur l'île Campobello au
Nouveau-Brunswick il aime le Canada
trois visites officielles lui
permettront de tisser des liens avec le
Premier ministre William line mais
kensuking la relation interpersonnelle
est toujours très importante la
politique c'est encore beaucoup une
question de décision personnelle
d'attitude de sentiments de penchant on
a vu des couples ou des diables
présidents Premier ministre fonctionner
à merveille grâce à une belle chimie
personnelle
pendant la guerre où the velviendra deux
fois à Québec se réunir avec Winston
Churchill et mes kendji King en 1943 à
1944 ensuite il y aura Harry Truman en
1947 la relation entre les deux pays est
au beau fixe tout comme celles avec mes
kensikin Truman sera le premier
président à s'adresser au Parlement
canadien oui
puis ce sera doit être Eisenhower à 1953
il a des affinités avec le Premier
ministre Louis Saint-Laurent comme lui
grand amateur de golf eisenhow aux
États-Unis et Louis Saint-Laurent au
Canada représente vraiment bien cette
époque télé noir et blanc papa a raison
époque de stabilité et de redressement
économique après la perturbation immense
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
vous avez mais ils s'entendra encore
mieux avec John dieffen Baker en 1958
conservateur de l'Ouest rural comme lui
c'est la guerre froide les deux pays
s'alignent militairement face à l'Union
soviétique c'est encore John dieffen
Baker qui accueillera le jeune président
John Kennedy en 1961 quelle différence
John dieffen Baker est plus âgé et
austère il est pro-britannique il est
pro tradition il tandis que Johanna
Kennedy est tout feu tout flamme jeune
cadrage et nerf veut refaire le monde
et ça ne le dérange pas de piétiner sur
le Canada s'il veut refaire le monde le
Canada refuse les missiles américains
sur son sol et quand Lindon Jones arrive
à Ottawa en 1966 il se heurte aux
manifestants contre la guerre au Vietnam
et au refus du Premier ministre l'est
biperson dit envoyer des soldats
ça se passe aussi très mal pour Richard
Nixon en 1972 Nexon a conservateur homme
de bon sens la majorité silencieuse
travaille et ordre et sécurité Pierre
Trudeau le progressiste du moins en
paroles ces deux êtres n'étaient pas
faits pour s'entendre on se souvient que
Nixon a porté un toast visionnaire au
nouveau-né des trudeaux juste en ces
termes au futur premier ministre du
Canada le Premier ministre Trudeau qui
accueille bien chaleureusement le
président des États-Unis le Ronald regen
et Pierre Trudeau ont visiblement
sympathisé en 1981 mais c'est en 1985 on
assiste à une véritable lune de miel
entre deux politiciens d'origine
irlandaise aux fameux sommets du Trèfle
de Québec
[Applaudissements]
à Brian me le René un accord de
libre-échange avec le puissant voisin
qu'il obtiendra avec le successeur de
Haagen George Bush qu'est-ce que c'est
la question je ne comprends pas ici
entre Brahim et le René et Georges Bush
père qui ont travaillé en ayant une
confiance mutuelle c'est vraiment une
étude de cas parfaite du fait que les
grands dossiers économiques aux
politiques sont considérablement aidés
facilités par les rapports personnels de
confiance entre les leaders
[Applaudissements]
tout comme pour ce couple improbable
Bill Clinton et Jean-Chrétien pourtant
différence d'âge d'à peu près 20 ans
milieu géographique très différents
Shawinigan arcanzar durant les années 90
les relations Clinton chrétien ont été
au beau fixe et par conséquence les
relations Canada américaines
Barack Obama a reçu un accueil triomphal
lors de ses visites au Canada
en 2009 elle est restée connue sous le
nom du sommet de la queue de castor
Barack Obama arpenter les rues du marché
By à Ottawa il est un succès de foule
digne des vedettes de Hollywood et en
2016 sous juste un Trudeau dans les
derniers mois de sa présidence le
Parlement canadien l'a acclamé au cri de
4 ans de plus
[Applaudissements]
enfin Donald Trump n'a jamais manifesté
beaucoup d'intérêt pour le Canada mais
on se souvient de lui au G7 de La
Malbaie lorsqu'il a qualifié juste un
Trudeau de faible et malhonnête
Jean-Michel le prince a du Canada
Montréal